come si chiama questa sera la scritta
benvenuti sono l'idea size
oggi nuova challenge e tre colori
dipanare 2 alle 3 di notte con nuovi
personaggi inquietanti
ajaccio sonno sappiamo per forza fare
questa challenge perché ce l'avete
richiesta in tantissime l'altro video vi
è piaciuto tantissimo vetro sotto un
falco di mi piace
quindi se volete anche la terza parte
lasciate un mi piace qua si nei commenti
che altri personaggi qualche vedere noi
abbiamo qua in questa nuova salentini
personaggi che voi ci avete richiesta
non voglia di cambiarmi e sono in
pigiama
mi piace il mio piccione di harry potter
guardiamo di quelli di berlino
graficamente come funziona questa sala
perché non ho visto il video precedente
una volta a testa dovremo pescare un
colore a caso di pennarelli e colorare i
vari personaggi horror e inquietanti
nello scorso video c'erano granny baldi
e lo naipaul e di chucky l'altro era
chucky la bambola assassina ci sia ma
soltanto per il coltello colorato
merlino e il re queta lo stesso non so
se lo sentite in giardino che abbaia a
quel comincia dalla lando la luna un
ingegnere berlino non abbaiò mai a
niente il che è molto strano comunque
iniziamo subito con il nostro primo
personaggio in poi vi lascerò il
sondaggio qua a ogni turno dovete votare
se vinco io se vince è vitale in base a
al disegno che mi piace di più come è
stato colorato quindi state bene attenti
a tutti i sistemi siete vi comodi e
prendi tipo corn e iniziamo subito dal
limo persona tour e via che piccolo qua
mista resto qua e mister mit
guardate un po più carino ingegnere e
molto molto molto brutto ok ora vediamo
che colori si aspettano sperando che non
si arrabbi e lewis terman super cattivo
e poi squarta squarta vabbè non andremo
nido ma anche vediamo chi è vietata
cornice sasso carta forno già sasso
pronto fai pesca fai vedere è un giallo
brent si posso farci qualcosa è cambiato
bellissimo serve marrone giallo e viola
viola oddio intervento si arrabbierà un
pochino se ti faccio il vestitino bello
quando io ci avrei sempre dal giallo o
rosa la loro opera del rosa questi tre
colori sono molto simili per ora quello
che volevi marrone e ultimo dolore per
me c'è l'esperto e pisello beckham e
ultimo colore per me è bellissimo ma chi
è colore marrone brutto se ribery giallo
scaduto iniziamo subito con era il
nostro mister mit così poi potrete
votare qual è il più bello
pronti il 3 2 1 viviano
mi è venuta l'idea che faccio la pelle
viola così tenetevi pure alieno e siamo
pronti a spalato 3 2 1
ottima sembrano due alieni io il mio in
realtà voglio che non esce mai
abitazione è iniziato con quel colore
della pella ero fatta verde e quindi lì
per lì ho detto me una linea robin li mi
sono preso top ix shrek
ecco perché ho pensato poi di fare anche
l'affare la camicia gialla proprio
appunto più o meno come il colore di
share h
anche il mio una sorta di alieno la
pelle viola le maniche marroncine e la
gonnellina anche se non è una gonnellina
marroncina quindi votate chi vince
questa tournée se vinco io o se vince
vitale votate il sondaggio e portiamo
sta e condotto da garanti per il secondo
personaggio a 321 sì e questo è un
secondo te chi è una persona che sta
formando come si chiama secondo te
questo personale billi il vagabondo a
casa come di tipo ii detersi alla fine a
testa è la metterebbe genitori e poi non
dirò ai luoghi dei personaggi non gli
faremo indovinare abitare qui non riesco
a giudicare questo e billy e una femmina
questa è la ndrina
entrino riconosciuta ora si arrabbierà
molto perché hai detto che è un maschio
e che si chiama billi
comunque andiamo a colorare la nostra
regione dice molto inquietante da questa
felice il sasso carta forbice sasso il
colore bellissimo sto troppo bene che
floor e vabbè si starà più o meno bene
forze forse riuscirò a fare qualcosa
bellissimo del cicr e dall altra gente
ma che devo fare
abete non verde con militanti a
riconoscere coloro che c'è buio guardate
[Risate]
è il mio colore preferito ma secondo lei
posso fare qualcosa col verde scuro
tocca andrea bellissimo ore altro
celeste ha capito devo fare il lupus le
ndrine padova
deve barrare parlare si no mentre nella
bellezza veste una pelle verde come
mezzo per l'essere stella renderebbe più
carina in effetti la pelle verde un pò
più inquietante queste cala sulla pelle
perde un uomo che i fronti a salvare la
nostra entry navi avviso solo che è
ancora più inquietante la staffetta non
so perché la tua mi fa più paura
la mia sembra un alieno guardate verde
alla faccia verde e il vestito blu doc
ice lestissimi sembra un alieno un po
imposte stato ci sia quella digitale
la mia invece c'è la pelle rosa ii b b e
il viso e le braccia sono rosa gli occhi
verdi dove hai fatto la bresso in realtà
è un pezzo di vestito lo so ma io quello
lì l'ho fatto apposta come se fosse la
barba visto che prima della gara
maschile
io ho fatto la barba a quello marrone
che questa parola in cui ho fatto la
barba scopra allora votate chi vince
questo turno se io o vitale in base al
sistema quotate qua passiamo oltre un
terzo cioè
ha paura chi è questo visto qual è il
vero nome
i premi why solo perché abbiamo visto
comunque è uno dei personaggi più
inquietanti che si siano in assoluto
mamma mia che paura e sapere nei
commenti se avete mai visto così lo
avete visto il film originale dal 1990
ho paura che in questo caso it si
arrabbierà veramente perché sai che vivo
e vagliato che sta nascosta tipo nelle
tubature o può benissimo allora qua però
potremmo anche sbagliare un po perché il
pagliaccio a pari col o peggio potremmo
anche insomma vediamo cosa ci capita in
base ai colori ma credo per far vice
sasso
cioè io questa volta dopo è cominciato
che cos'è marrone e un primo errore ti
capita marrone 99 tra l'altro festa del
marrone scurissimo io voglio io vi posso
almeno posso fare il caffè che ha
promesso che correre un altro celeste
chelsea chiaro per affrontare gli
occhietti sono diventate bello e frison
che colore il rosa ora giovane rosa con
loro anche l'ala già l'ocra scusa e io
creai poca mentalità ancora su due
marroni un cielo
prendo da ultimo per te
fanta serve no non poteva mancare il
problema di tutti allora ciao vecchio ma
perché il rosso non capita mai forse non
è il rock ci sono due rosa 2 rosa almeno
più prima ne avevo preso uno che era che
somigliava molto a rosa non trovo più
grosso sasso rosso bene scrivete nei
commenti se dobbiamo cambiare pennarelli
sono la prossima volta
oppure potremmo farlo via parco donne
con i colori a cera o coni con le
tempere oppure con gli acquerelli quello
mi piace e volete che faccia con il
carico dei ragazzi e la salubrità
piazzata raggiunge i 10 mila mi piace il
prossimo sarà con i personaggi che
scegliete voi e con occorre il tempo era
in votate nel sondaggio vi lascio anche
questo è giusto che vi farà non so di
che colore farli i capelli belli capelli
blu sarebbero molto bene e meriterebbero
abbott i capelli comunque sono proprio
da allora devo capire bene
un ospite ma mi sa che birbante prima il
giorno dove deve controllare cosa stiamo
facendo altrimenti non è connivente
inquadra berlin e nelle 782 rotte di
wight allora devo dire che tu e molto
fashion perchè è vero non ha paura per
le manopole di gente voleva allora il
mio è un po più ti porle chino mischiato
un po i colori gialloblù battono rete un
po più facebook you know arlecchino tipo
corrette mischiato un po i colori un po
di giallo un po di marrone un po di blu
e gli ho fatto gli occhi celesti sembra
quasi più bello dell'originale perché
penny wise e molto tutto vediamo
produttività le scene più belle sono tre
i colori e briosa di tutti e tre però
quello più scuro l'ho usato del marrone
che scorre rosato per i beni che lei
liner degli occhi che si basi elettorali
che fa sì che si mise bomba via alla tua
scelta
votate chi vince questo termine aiuti il
pesante datate se vinco io o servizi e
vitale in summer league
berlino che c'è vuole distruggere il
berlino gli sta molto perché non sei
riccardo berlino l'interruzione
interruzione ma mentre i programmi per
voi
ok ragazzi quarto così il turno merlino
nun tene voluto andare io in quel modo
voleva possa stare qua quindi noi
lasciamo qualche che non sale in estate
la lotta per formare dovrebbe stare lì
tranquillo io non riesco a sedermi era
sveglio perché è preoccupata mi arriva è
lui che vince tu che ci fai solo
significa che il fumo personaggio che è
come si chiama questa satira non è
stavolta resta silvia chietti silvia
prima vitale ha detto un altro nome come
era la farina mando arriva la carrà
bianca la mia e questo fatto stabilirà
chi è questa tesi vicino con la s sì
insomma samantha sua migliore sabrina io
so chi è
si chiama samaras amara la bambina di
the ring e pratica esce da quello che
sento è quella di the ring pochissimo
per lo fa era tutta bianca e nera vede
già pronta che si no il colore st marano
l'abitare si ammira poverina summit come
sicuramente
sarà un po strano mettere un po di
colori interessante se ti capita di
giocare la carta non c'è senso che
colore è bello ma si può star bene se
uscita dal pozzo sarà un po sporca dai
guarda che colore rosa o io guardo io
perché sono confezione a volte sbagli
colore rosa buona terra e più lilla ma
le facce il vestitino nella tarda sera
per amore bello caldo potrebbe stare
potrebbe bastare ultimo colore per me
blue bergoglio lo l'oscuro mi piacerebbe
farla investite tipo principesco lì non
puoi fare gli la faccia bella verde non
ce lo hai perde questa e blu e verde blu
dai pronti ad ora dai gli faccio il
vestitino rosa la rende più carina visto
che è bruttissima allora iniziamo con
quella digitale vediamo un lungo mela
colorata allora viso rosa e mani rosa è
molto pallida in realtà quindi già con
queste viessmann i rosa sarà volta
arrabbiata camicetta gialla e con blu e
rosa
scarpette gialli ne fa paura farà io
invece ho fatto una versione tipo
alimentati le ho fatto la pelle blu
scuro tipo verde il vestito rosa e
marrone e i capelli li ho lasciati così
interi quindi votate chi vince questo
turno
vuol dire che a me piace più con
l'attività a me piace di più lo giuro
non fatico a del suo mezzo
chi vince questo turno barba mi aveva
veramente paura sfamare comunque vera
che scolari ha la faccia blu
le scopriremo chi ha vinto questa
challenge in base ai vostri voti
un'altra volta l'avete fatta pensare a
me grazie
mi raccomando votate per i disegni non
perla per vero sempre per il design
ovvero l'altra volta il mio era più
bello l'inizio dei tuoi era la più bella
latina quindi mani anzi accesa stati un
po di pareggi tra l'altro bene lasciato
un bel mi piace se volete vedere anche
terza parte e ora vi lasciamo qua 4 a
castellini si può cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite
bravissimo